somit kommen wir zum nächsten
themenbereich ich bitte die platzwechsel
relativ zügig vorzunehmen so dass wir
die debatte um eine nächste dem bereich
ist familie senioren frauen und jugend
dort ist ja die ministerin anne spiegel
die neue die 40-jährige parteilinke der
die 40 ihre partei linke ist ministerin
in rheinland pfalz gewesen zunächst
hatte das
kabinett von
und anfang des jahres wurde sie dann
klimaschutz und umweltministerin
[Musik]
in das muster ist das kein problem aber
das ist doch eine grosse menge wieder
wurde unter anderem frau lambrecht frau
gallwitz
fräser und er schmidt sind nicht mdbs
das
plenum wechselt jetzt sozusagen sich
nochmal aus die mit
führen die nehmen jetzt hier platz
während die von arbeit und soziales die
politiker werden denn liebe kollegen
verlassen die neue bundesregierung will
ihr eine reform des familienrechts das
ehegattensplitting soll wegfallen
die gesondert 16 jahren gehen dürfen und
das werbeverbot für abteilungs ärzte
soll fallen eine spiegel lässt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter abgeordnete sehr geehrte zu
hörende zunächst einmal wünsche ich
ihnen allen noch ein frohes neues jahr
und vor allem gesundheit ich habe mich
sehr gefreut dieses wichtige amt zu
übernehmen das ministerium kennt bereits
viele bezeichnungen und ich trete
entschieden allen entgegen die sagen es
gehe angeblich um sogenannte weiche
themen nein im gegenteil
dieses ministerium und seine themen die
sind ganz nah dran an den menschen und
an ihrem alltag ob es
ob es um kinder geht auch gebeutelt von
der pandemie zunehmend mit psychischen
erkrankungen ob es um mütter und väter
geht oft unter großem druck ältere
menschen engagierte frauen jugendliche
menschen in all ihrer vielfalt ihre
bedürfnisse und rechte werden im
mittelpunkt meiner politik stehen
[Applaus]
familie dass es überall dort wo menschen
verantwortung füreinander übernehmen
die ampel will diese vielfalt endlich im
recht abbilden und allen familienformen
anerkennung zukommen lassen warum auch
nicht wir werden
wir werden diese gelebte
gesellschaftliche vielfalt ganz konkret
unterstützen indem wir beispielsweise
bonus eltern in patchworkfamilien
rechtlich absichern indem wir lesbische
mütter die zusammen ein kind bekommen
von anfang an die rechtliche anerkennung
als eltern bekommen
und dazu
dazu gehört auch die international
beachtete benennung eines vier
beauftragten und ich freue mich sehr
dass wenn leben an dieses wichtige amt
mit leben füllt
in der aktuellen bewohner situation ist
es wichtig das leben von kindern und
jugendlichen nicht erneut vorschnell
einzuschränken und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass es eine große politische
mehrheit gibt die sich klar dafür
einsetzt dass wir zu allerletzt über die
schließung von schulen und kitas
sprechen und nicht zuallererst und
darüber hinaus ist ab viel sport kultur
viele kindergeburtstage und viele
jugendbegegnungen leider ausgefallen und
deshalb werden wir ein neues
zukunftspaket für bewegung kultur und
gesundheit auf den weg bringt um kinder
und jugendliche in dieser schwierigen
phase zu stärken
und wir werden endlich eine
kindergrundsicherung einführen als
kampfansage an kinderarmut und damit
familien finanzielle unterstützung auch
viel unkomplizierter und online
beantragen können das wird der große
wurf werden um familien in deutschland
aus der armut zu wohnen meine sehr
geehrten abgeordnete
und
weil diese große reform nicht schnell
umgesetzt werden kann werden wir
gemeinsam mit dem
bundessozialministerium zeitnah ein
sofort zuschlag für kinder einführen die
auf unterstützung angewiesen sind ebenso
wichtig
ebenso wichtig und das hat die korona
pante mir erneut gezeigt ist es dass in
den schulen und kitas die kinder und
jugendlichen kontakt mit gleichaltrigen
haben und deshalb um diese qualität
weiter zu stärken und zu sichern werden
wir das gute kita gesetz fortentwicklung
und in ein qualitäts entwicklungs gesetz
mit klaren standards überführen und
zusammen mit den ländern den
ganztagsschul ausbau deutlich
voranbringen wir sind dafür einen
wichtigen schritt
bereits vor weihnachten gegangen und
haben die länder mit insgesamt 3,5
milliarden bundesmittel
unterstützt was kann eine gute
familienpolitik noch leisten dass alle
kinder dazu gehören stichwort inklusive
jugendhilfe unter dem dach der
jugendhilfe soll nicht mehr
unterschieden werden ob kinder mit oder
ohne behinderung auf ihrem lebensweg
begleitet werden und wir wollen eine
partnerschaftliche aufteilung von
familie von care arbeit ermöglichen mit
einer reform des elterngeldes und nach
der geburt eines kindes sollen die
partner in der regel die väter zwei
wochen bezahlte freistellung nehmen
könnt denn direkt nach der geburt
gehören beide elternteile zum
neugeborenen dass es eine ganze andere
zeit im leben einer familie
zur familie gehören aber alle
generationen und wir wollen die jungen
menschen mit einem nationalen
aktionsplan und der absenkung des
wahlalters auf 16 jahre in ihren
lebenschancen und beteiligungsrechten
stärken wir wollen aber gleichzeitig
auch den blick auf ältere menschen in
unserer gesellschaft richten und da geht
es mehr als um die themen pflege und
gesundheit es geht darum dass wir ihre
anliegen und nöte
selbstverständlich mitdenken durch
digital packt alte durch mein
mehrgenerationenhäuser aber auch durch
eine strategie gegen einsamkeit
und meine sehr geehrten
abgeordnetenbezüge als feministin möchte
ich die frauenrechte in den fokus rücken
es geht um gleiche rechte es geht um
gleichgemacht gleichen einfluss gleiche
bezahlung gleich viele frauen in den
chefetagen
wir werden darüber hinaus mit dem
bundesjustizministerium den § 209 10 r
streichen und damit die vorgestrige
kriminalisiert von
und ärzteschaft beenden und wir werden
den kampf gegen sexismus gegen gewalt an
frauen und mädchen mit aller kraft
aufnehmen denn dabei handelt es sich
eben nicht um beziehungstaten da ist
kein privater streit eskaliert es geht
um partner oder ex-partner die alle
zweieinhalb tage in deutschland eine
frau töten das sind vermietet das sind
abscheuliche verbrechen und wir sollten
sie auch genauso hinein und dagegen
dagegen
müssen wir alle gemeinsam aufstehen und
der gemeinsamen erklärung des runden
tisches gegen gewalt an frauen taten
folgen lassen und unser hilfesystem auf
1 finanziell sicheres fundament stellen
und ein letzter punkt ist mir auch
besonders wichtig wir haben eine
abteilung für demokratie im haus und ja
leider gibt es sie die hässliche fratze
von hass und hetze im netz auf der
straße auch immer wieder montags und
deshalb werden wir diejenigen stärken
die sich in diesen zeiten für ein
friedliches demokratisches und
vielfältiges miteinander in unserem land
einsetzen mit einem demokratie fördern
dieses gemeinsam mit dem punkt
das wird klare passiert so
sehr geehrter abgeordnete als ich den
koalitionsvertrag zu den themen des
ministeriums gelesen habe habe ich bei
jedem einzelnen sachs gedacht endlich
endlich packen wir diese wichtigen
projekte ab ich freue mich gemeinsam mit
einem tollen team im ministerium mit
hoch motivierten mitarbeitenden auf die
zusammenarbeit mit ihnen einen
herzlichen dank
nun müssten alle spiegel freut sich über
den koalitionsvertrag das ist eine frohe
kunde
und sie hatte noch einmal ausgeführt die
reform des familienrechts ist ein
zentraler punkt der künftigen jahre ihre
und politik ihres hauses rede die fans
nächste dorothee bär sie ist
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
geworden der cdu csu für diesen
spiegel ich freue mich sehr sie hier
heute zu sehen weil ich mir nach dem
ganz vielen interviews in den letzten
tagen des selbsternannten familien
ministers marco buschmann schon die
frage gestellt habe auch er nicht
tauglich für die familienpolitik der
ampel vorstellen will weil anscheinend
hat das justizministerium sich das zur
großen aufgabe gemacht den großen wurf
ihrer familienpolitik zu machen und das
finde ich schade deswegen schön dass die
zuständige ministerin heute hier selbst
erschienen ist
wir haben in den letzten jahren sehr
viel als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion für
die familien auf den weg gebracht und
zwar das spannende ist für alle familien
in diesem land weil wir nicht
unterscheiden weil wir keine gesunden
gruppen heraus ziehen weil wir den
anspruch haben in der mitte der
gesellschaft für alle da zu sagen
wir sind da
würde ich so genannten traditionellen
familien die sie meistens auch etwas mit
einem gewissen schon eher und igitt
behandeln wir sind da für
patchworkfamilien für alleinerziehende
immer mit einem ganzheitlichen ansatz
immer im ausgleich zwischen den
generationen aber immer in der mitte der
gesellschaft weil unser anspruch
entsteht bei den ganz konkreten
herausforderungen unser anspruch ist wir
kümmern uns um alle und ich darf es auch
an zwei beispielen die sie vielleicht
nicht auf den ersten blick auf dem
schirm haben auch mal darstellen das
erste ist wir haben federführend von der
union aus mit dem baukindergeld in der
letzten legislaturperiode auch eigenheim
geschaffen für familien in unserem land
davon waren über 75 prozent der familien
mit einem haushalts jahreseinkommen von
weniger als 50.000 euro weiß auch
familien brauchen ein dach über dem kopf
und das war federführend der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion zu verdanken
dass wir das haben leisten können
ein zweites thema dass es auch ohne die
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion nicht gegeben
hätte ist dass wir uns um die
alleinerziehenden in diesem land
gekümmert haben wir haben in deutschland
mehr als 2,7 millionen alleinerziehende
und wir haben als union auch in der
letzten
legislatur in der letzten koalition auch
in teilen gegen die spd durchgesetzt
dass wir die verdoppelung des
entlastungsbetrag das über 4000 euro
haben heben können damit deutlich mehr
im portemonnaie glaubt für die
alleinerziehende denn die die doppelte
verantwortung alleine schultern und auch
da werden wir eben nicht nachlassen weil
wir genau wissen dass gerade in von demi
zeiten jemand der alleine die last zu
tragen hat noch viel mehr hat leisten
müssen auch deswegen sind wir die
anwältinnen und anwälte der
alleinerziehenden
das sind nur zwei beispiele die zeigen
dass wir für alle familien darf sind
dass wir unterschiedliche lebensmodelle
unterschiedliche familien modelle
unterstützen dass wir auch die parteien
der wahlfreiheit sind weil wir kein
bestimmtes familienmodell vorschreiben
oder so tun als ob irgendwas moderner
ist als was anderes ist finde ich
ohnehin converting hier ein bisschen
peinlich liebe ampelkoalition zu
behaupten es geht in der familienpolitik
und modernität also sie dürfen einfach
modernität nicht beliebigkeit übersetzen
oder verwechseln das finde ich wirklich
schwierig dass es nicht muss was hier an
beliebigkeit machen
dass es eine verwechslung des falsch
verstandene toleranz und wir werden ganz
genau hinschauen bei ihren vorhaben
beispielsweise bei der sogenannten
verantwortungsgemeinschaft dies im
familienrecht verankern wollen da würde
ich ihnen allen mal jetzt wir gehen ja
langsam aufs wochenende zumal die
lektüre der bundesrats protokolle aus
dem letzten jahr empfehlen noch zu
beginn des letzten jahres wurde der fdp
antrag abgelehnt und auch mit den
stimmen beispielsweise der spd und der
grünen im letzten jahr und wenn man sich
mal die reden auch der grünen anschaut
im letzten jahr zur
verantwortungsgemeinschaft da die
kommune kollegin gesagt dass es nicht
unterstützen weil die fdp ein reines
steuersparmodell hier durchsetzen will
und jetzt plötzlich sollst die
gemeinsame politik sein das buch nicht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir lehnen auf jeden fall diese ehe
light ab weil es eben nicht nur ein
steuersparmodell ist sondern weil es
ganz viele probleme nach sich ziehe die
sie vielleicht gar nicht noch auf dem
schirm haben aber dafür haben sie ja uns
für uns steht die ehe unter dem ganz
besonderen schutz nicht nur des
grundgesetzes und sie beinhaltet rechte
und sehbehinderte eben auch pflichten
aber es bleibt halt auch nicht mehr viel
übrig wenn es ein rechtsinstitut gibt
dass zwar bei sonnenschein und
bürokratisch zugänglich jederzeit auf
lösbar sein soll aber eben auch wenn es
schwierig wird ganz große probleme mit
sich bringt und ich bitte sie einfach
weil wir tun das täglich wir haben
täglich die kinder im blick und jedes
einzelne kind in diesem land und wenn
sie sich mal mit den juristen in diesem
land unterhalten wenn sie schnell
feststellen dass die sano danke die
ampel bringt uns mehr geld weil es wird
viel komplizierter und es wird viel
weniger ums kindeswohl gehen und
außerdem ist auch die
verantwortungsgemeinschaft etwas was sie
auch nicht wollen würden beispielsweise
auch entlang schein für die vielehe wenn
sie sagen es geht nicht mehr um zwei
leute können auch 34 was sie mir nach
oben noch grenzen gesetzt es macht doch
alles keinen sinn liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der antike
es ist auch bei scheidungen gibt schon
so dass es kompliziert ist das
kindeswohl bei zwei streitenden parteien
durch zu gefährden ist es denn damit die
zum schluss das passt alles nicht wir
stehen für die kinder wir stehen für die
mitte der gesellschaft wenn sie die
mitte der gesellschaft entlasten wollen
haben sie uns an ihrer seite was auch
bei steigenden energiepreisen bei der
höchsten inflation seit 30 jahren
dringend geboten ist wenn das kindeswohl
an erster stelle stehen soll wenn die
unionsfraktion dabei sein wenn sie
meinen modern ist beliebig dann sind wir
sicherlich eine sehr streitbare
opposition film haben
ich erteile zu ihrer ersten rede das
wort jasmina und horst aus
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit zehn jahren
bin ich in dieses land gekommen als
kriegsflüchtling aus bosnien ich hatte
damals einen kleinen rucksack mit ein
paar puppen dabei mehr nicht ich weiß
was es bedeutet als kind zeitweise
nichts zu haben es war mein großes glück
dass sich eine liebevolle und auch
finanziell relativ abgesicherte
pflegemutter hatte die mir geholfen hat
beim start in mein neues leben hier
erfolgreich in der schule zu sein später
zu studieren meinen interessen
nachzugehen an klassenfahrten und
ausflügen teilzunehmen freunde zu finden
kurzum gesagt am gesellschaftlichen
leben teilhaben zu können ich hatte
glück andere hatten und haben nach wie
vor pech sollen glück und pech unser
maßstab sein ganz sicher nicht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich möchte dass
die zukunft von kindern nicht von glück
abhängt sondern dass kinder in unserem
land alle möglichkeiten und förderung
erhalten die sie für ihre entwicklung
brauchen
wir werden familien ganz konkret
unterstützen und entlasten den strauß an
maßnahmen und leistungen die familien
betreffen werden wir bündeln
modernisieren und auf ganz neue beine
stellen wir werden das elterngeld
vereinfachen indem wir zum beispiel
einen anspruch für pflegeeltern
einführen und die partnermonate beim
basis elterngeld um einen monat
erweitern auch für alleinerziehende aus
eigener
aus eigener erfahrung weiß ich dass jede
hilfe für alleinerziehende mütter und
väter eine wichtige ist denn auch ich
habe zeitweise meine tochter alleine
großgezogen
eine besondere entlastung für
alleinerziehende für familien allgemein
aber vor allem für die kinder selbst ist
die kindergrundsicherung lange haben wir
darauf hingewirkt und endlich ja endlich
können wir sie nun in dieser koalition
umsetzen
es ist doch mehr als beschämend dass
laut der bertelsmann stiftung in
deutschland jedes fünfte kind in armut
lebt
kinderarmut ist oft versteckte armut
eltern versuchen alles damit dass arm
sein der kinder nicht bemerkt wird
sie sparen sich selbst um den kindern
etwas bieten zu können wenn ich mutter
von zwei kindern aber genauer hinschaue
sehe ich große unterschiede es gibt
kinder die jeden tag nach der schule
aktivitäten nachgehen von musik über
sport freunde treffen ins kino gehen und
dann gibt es die kinder die nicht mal
eine geburtstagsfeier im jahr
organisiert bekommen weil schlicht das
geld dafür fehlt damit muss jetzt
endlich schluss sein wir werden kinder
aus der hartz 4 und am
die kindergrundsicherung ist ein
meilenstein auf diesem weg sie bedeutet
einen grundlegenden systemwechsel
die grundsicherung wird die bisherigen
finanziellen unterstützungen für kinder
bündeln also das kindergeld den
steuerfreibetrag aber auch alle anderen
leistungen die ärmere familien nicht in
anspruch nehmen warum nicht weil sie
sich ganz oft schämen zum amt zu gehen
oder weil die antragsstellung so
kompliziert ist dass sie es eben nicht
tun mit der kindergrundsicherung bauen
wir die bürokratischen hürden ab und
bringen keine familie in die situation
beschämt um leistungen zu bitten wie
gutscheine fürs schwimmbad zu besuch
oder die übernahme der kosten für den
tanzkurs der tochter
die grundsicherung besteht aus zwei
komponenten einem garantiebetrag den
alle erhalten und einem gestaffelten
zusatzbetrag der abhängig vom einkommen
der eltern ausbezahlt wird
das heißt kinder aus familien mit
niedrigem einkommen bekommen automatisch
mehr geld und das ist gut so denn kinder
in armut brauchen unsere unterstützung
und zwar jetzt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
zwei kindern geht es gut sie sind gesund
und wahrscheinlich werden sie nicht in
armut leben müssen das wünsche ich mir
für alle kinder in unserem land
unabhängig von ihrer herkunft unabhängig
vom geldbeutel ihrer eltern
respekt heißt für mich kein kind soll
mehr in armut aufwachsen das sagt unser
kanzler olaf scholz ganz richtig ich
freue mich auf die gemeinsame umsetzung
der kindergrundsicherung und vieler
anderer wichtiger vorhaben in der ampel
auch mit ihnen frau ministerin legen wir
los
das hat jetzt redet das kostet 39
jährige sozialdemokrat in buchs
installierung auf zu beginn des bosnien
krieges wurde sie im oktober 92 schwer
durch eine granate verletzt und verlor
ihren rechten arm weil sie in sarajevo
nicht ausreichend versorgt werden konnte
flüchtete sie mit ihrem vater aus
sarajevo gelangte da bonn wo sie dann
später adoptiert wurde und ein
bewegender lebenslauf von ihr heute hier
ihr erst rede sie hat ja auch viel
applaus aus den reihen der abgeordneten
dafür gekommen
zähne reichert jetzt die fdp ministerin
spiegel durch die ungeheuerliche
wählertäuschung des herrn lindner in der
frage der impfpflicht und der
freiheitsrechte führt heute eine
ministerin das familienministerium die
aus einer partei kommt die ein unklares
verhältnis zu pädophilie und inzest hat
teile der grünen grüne jugend und
liberale wollen den sex unter verwandten
legalisieren nach ihrer auffassung
entspricht dies dieses verbot einer
altbackenen moralvorstellung die nicht
mehr in die neue grüne diverse
definition von ehe und familie passt die
neue familienministerin will familien
neu definieren die mehrheit also die
gesellschaftliche realität wird
umgedeutet und der ideologie einer
links-grünen polit blase unterworfen im
klartext heißt das die ampel will die
traditionelle familie und damit das
fundament unseres zusammenlebens
zerstören sie wollen die natürliche
familien grundlage von vater mutter und
kindern abschaffen sie wollen ehe und
familie die unter den besonderen schutz
der staatlichen ordnung stehen einer
künstlich geschaffenen
verantwortungsgemeinschaft
gleichstellen wer vater und mutter zu
einer beliebigkeit macht der muss sich
kritik gefallen lassen
ein kind kann bis zu vier eltern haben
egal welchen geschlechts in dem von
ihnen angestrebten
verantwortungsgemeinschaft ist alles
möglich mehr elternschaft co
mutterschaft elternschaft wird fortan
nicht mehr durch naturwissenschaftliche
fakten sondern durch lösbare verträge
definiert es ist der weg in eine
gesellschaft meine damen und herren ohne
familie ohne herkunft ohne identität und
ohne heimat
kinder werden unter der ampel zum
spielball der lsb die lobby zitat der
neuen ministerin auch heute hier in der
bisher hängt eine unnötig
diskriminierende bürokratie daran wenn
zwei frauen ein kind miteinander
bekommen auch wenn man nur politik
philosophie oder psychologie studiert
hat sollte man wissen zwei frauen können
gar kein kind miteinander bekommen das
ist realität das ist natur wissenschaft
die infantilisierung und realitätsferne
hat im familienministerium einzug
gehalten oder besser eine biologie leute
wenn meine damen und herren
richtig heißt es wenn zwei frauen ein
kind produziert bekommen und dadurch
wird das kind für sie zum produkt zu
ihrem 100 tage programm gehört außerdem
ein gleichstellungsgesetz für die
tätigkeit der bundesregierung jede
vorlage die ins kabinett kommt soll
darauf geprüft werden ob die
gleichstellungs und frauen politischen
grundsätzen rechnung trägt meine damen
und herren familien in deutschland
hätten einen familien check verdient
denn sie sind die die deutschland am
laufen halten meine damen und herren
familien aus vater mutter und kindern
sind das erfolgsmodell familien werden
auch noch dann da sein und den
fortbestand der gesamten menschheit
sichern wenn regierungen und politiker
die kultur herkunft wissenschaft und
sprache umschreiben vollen längst auf
dem schrottplatz der geschichte der
ideologien geendet sind meine damen und
herren
vor dem 100 tage programm der ministerin
gehört auch ein sofort zuschlag an
bedürftige familien der dann ausgezahlt
werden soll er soll in zweistelliger
höhe sein es ist schon ein hohn wenn
denn besonders familien leiden unter den
hohen energiepreisen den hohen
kraftstoffpreisen und den preisanstieg
bei lebensmitteln
diese regierung treibt diesen
preisanstieg auf allen ebenen maßgeblich
voran und preis dann eine leistung in
zweistelliger höhe als großen erfolg
dazu muss man nichts mehr sagen meine
damen und herren
auch können sie eine grundsicherung
gegen kinderarmut einführen gegen armut
hilft aber kein geld das man dauerhaft
nur vom staat bekommt dauerhaft hilft
nur arbeit von der man leben kann meine
damen und herren
nur die ard will starke bürger und
starke familien die den staat nicht
brauchen grüne und linke wollen das
nicht denn in der familie werden werte
vermittelt sie steht für vertrauen und
verantwortung
familien sind schon seit vielen
jahrzehnten und eigentlich schon immer
resistent gegen linx ideologische
umtriebe und deshalb wollen linke auch
schon seit ihrer aus ihrer gesamten
geschichte heraus die kontrolle über die
heranwachsenden kinder gewinnen auch
bundeskanzler scholz hat das bereits
gesagt und die rechte von eltern und
kindern beschneiden und dafür wollen sie
auch kinderrechte im grundgesetz
verankern damit dann eine komplett
staatliche erziehung möglich wird meine
damen und herren
seit fast zwei jahren aber bestimmt
dieser staat ja schon über das leben
unserer kinder sie haben das leben der
kinder zu einer verhandlungsmasse ihrer
corona politik gemacht sie haben sich
der schweren form der
kindeswohlgefährdung schuldig gemacht
keine treffen mit freunden kein sport
kein austausch mit gleichgesinnten im
präsenzunterricht vor allem aber die
üble rhetorik mit der sie bis heute
unsere kinder zu oma und opa umbringen
diskreditieren haben sensible
kinderseelen zerstört meine damen und
herren
allein im märz bis mai 20 21 mussten
bundesweit 500 kinder nach
suizidversuchen auf intensivstationen
behandelt werden die zahl der kinder die
nach selbstmordversuchen auf
intensivstationen landete hat sich
vervierfacht das sind zahlen
studie der essener uniklinik die
kinderlose ex kanzlerin merkel sagte im
januar 21 ich lasse mir nicht anhängen
dass sich kinder quälen aber ich sage
ihnen genau das tut diese
bundesregierung meine damen und herren
sie treiben kinder in depressionen den
best störungen in angstzustände
sie treiben die kinder dort hin dass sie
oft nicht mehr leben wollen und das ist
eine große schuld die sie auf sich
geladen haben meine damen und herren ich
bitte sie im namen unserer kinder heben
sie alle kinder betreffenden maßnahmen
umgehend auf die familienministerin hat
sich zu diesen erschreckenden zahlen bis
heute überhaupt nicht geäußert das
wundert nicht sie hat ja wichtigeres zu
tun sie muss einen beauftragten für
akzeptanz sexueller und geschlechtlicher
vielfalt ins am tiefen was sind schon
kinder leben gegen grüne lobbyarbeit
meine damen und herren
alle fraktionen außer der asd in diesem
hause haben das recht verwirkt das wort
kinderrechte in den mund zu nehmen mit
der ampel koalition ist in deutschland
eine regierung aktiv geworden die die
aktive sterbebegleitung unseres landes
sich auf die fahnen geschrieben hat und
meine damen und herren nur die afg
qualität in diesem land ich komme zum
schluss für freiheit und
selbstverantwortung von eltern und
kindern wir stehen für grundrechte und
identität wir sind die einzige stimme
der freiheit in diesem parlament vielen
dank
und jetzt muss ich noch meine
staubschutz maske aufsetzen
[Applaus]
tja damen und herren sie befinden sich
in der debatte im deutschen bundestag
zum bereich familie senioren frauen und
jugend
und die nächste drin güte jensen und die
32 jährige war vor vier jahren als ich
in den bundestag einzog die jüngste
abgeordnete des hauses und sie bekam
gleich den vorsitz im bundestags
ausschuss für menschenrechte und
humanitäre hilfe in dieser legislatur
ist jetzt stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
[Musik]
wir halten das aus und deswegen komme
ich jetzt zu den plänen der
ampelkoalition in einem bereich wo es
nicht nur um ein familienbild geht
sondern um so viel mehr liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen jetzt die
positiven rückmeldungen die ich auf die
vorhaben dieser neuen koalition erhalten
habe ging es vor allen dingen um den
zuspruch für die abschaffung von 219 a
um die liberalisierung von familienrecht
und bei diesen rückmeldungen da klang
vor allen dingen eines durch dass das
eine art befreiungsschlag ist freilich
eine koalition und einen kranz zum
jahrhundert nicht mehr an diese
kolleginnen und kollegen den menschen im
persönlichsten lebensbereichen ihre
moralvorstellung an oft drücken zu
wollen sondern weil wir ihnen etwas
zutraut und zwar selbstbestimmt
verantwortungsbewusst verantwortungsvoll
elementarste aspekte ihres lebens zu
entwerfen und für viele viele menschen
in diesem land ist das eine große
erleichterung denn unsere gesellschaft
hat die union bereits in diesen fragen
schon vor jahren überholt und frau bas
geht nicht nur aus prinzip und
modernität sondern um realität denn wir
wollen das was schon längst beliebte uns
akzeptierte lebens entführung
familienform endlich auch rechtlich
abgebildet werden und das eint uns hier
in dieser koalition und zwar nicht weil
wir uns irgendwie im vertrag geschrieben
haben sondern weil wir davon zutiefst
überzeugt sind und ich will auch
erklären warum seinen eigenen weg zu
gehen das ist ein gefühl und das hat
nicht nur etwas mit beruflicher
lebensplanung zu tun ein
selbstbestimmtes leben das fängt mit
träumen an mit einem ziel auf das man
hinarbeiten möchte für viele menschen
besteht dieser lebenstraum darin eine
familie zu gründen die meisten von uns
ist es ein tiefes bedürfnis unser leben
mit menschen zu teilen wir schätzen oder
lieben denen wir vertrauen und für die
wir verantwortung übernehmen möchten und
diese entwürfe die sich daraus
ergebenden die spielen wir nicht
moralisch gegeneinander aus und über die
fällen wir auch kein urteil wir werden
unser bestes geben
vielfältigen lebensentwürfe zu
ermöglichen haben jetzt alle bürgerinnen
und bürgern lebensträume träumen und vor
allen dingen verwirklichen können indem
wir familienrecht liberalisieren wir
haben es schon in vielen reden gehört in
dem wir
indem wir ungewollt kinderlose besser
unterstützen und zwar ohne
diskriminierung ihres familienstandes
oder ihrer sexuellen identität indem wir
bedingungen verbessern damit familie und
beruf miteinander vereinbart werden
könnten liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lebensträume die entstehen in der
kindheit wenn man bücher liest wenn man
mit freunden spielt wenn man an orte
reist in dem man noch nie war in dem man
hobbys ausübt und kinder die in armut
aufwachsen das haben wir heute auch
schon eindrücklich auch aus persönlichen
erfahrungen gehört haben weniger dieser
möglichkeiten und obwohl ihnen ihre
liebevollen eltern alles möglich machen
was irgendwie geht müssen sie die
erfahrung machen dass sie nur in einem
ganz begrenzten rahmen träumen dürfen
und genau da da müssen wir politisch
unterstützen dass es die verantwortung
die wir hier haben und die wir gemeinsam
mit der koalition auf den weg bringen
wollen deswegen werden wird eine
kindergrundsicherung etablieren und ein
digitales immer chancen
die pandemie bekämpfung in den letzten
zwei jahren gingen auf kosten der kinder
auf kosten von familien und jugendlichen
und wir sollten uns hier in diesem hohen
haus sehr bewusst sein und ich glaube
die koalition ist das definitiv dass
schule mehr als ein kapiteln ein
mathebuch ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen da haben wir einiges
gutzumachen das wollen wir sehr gerne
machen wir freuen uns auf die
zusammenarbeit die ministerin spiegel
wir wünschen ihnen viel erfolg wir
stehen an ihrer seite und vor allen
dingen viel freude bei den anstehenden
projekten die vor indien
[Applaus]
die nächste rednerin zum bereich familie
senioren frauen und jugend heidi dann
eine
krankheit heidi jetzt kann ich noch mal
neu an heidi wieder gehörten hinreichen
ecke von der linken sie ist
frauenpolitische sprecherin ihrer
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen beim lesen des
koalitionsvertrags habe ich mich kurz
gefragt ob mir da vielleicht ein paar
kapitel fehlen denn natürlich stehen da
viele schöne worte da wurden auch einige
vorgetragen aber die vorhaben der ampel
koalition leisten nicht so wirklich ein
beitrag dazu die schere zwischen arm und
reich in deutschland endlich zu
schließen
vermögenssteuer fehlanzeige bürger in
versicherungen fehlanzeige abschaffung
von hartz vier jahren das fehlanzeige
und nein ein neuer name hilft uns nicht
wirklich weiter
und nach vielen jahren arbeit in
verschiedenen bereichen der kinder und
jugendhilfe kann ich ihnen nur sagen
auch hier liegt einiges im argen und die
folgen der pandemie sind gravierend zwar
diskutieren alle darüber wie der
verlorene schulstoff aufgeholt werden
kann aber kaum jemand redet darüber was
es mit kindern und jugendlichen nacht
wenn sie zwei jahre lang fast keine
sozialen kontakte haben und hier sind
kinder armer familien massiv
benachteiligt im eigenen garten mit
computer ist so eine quarantäne
ehrlicherweise einfacher zu ertragen als
mit zwei geschwistern auf einigen
wenigen quadratmetern
bereits nach dem ersten locker und
stiegen depressionen bei jugendlichen
auf das zweieinhalbfache des
vorkrisenniveaus und auch hier kann ich
aus meiner praxis berichten ich war da
noch vor wenigen monaten die kinder und
jugendlichen gehen gerade kaputt aber
anstatt nur zu pöbeln und diese kinder
zu instrumentalisieren sage ich wir
brauchen deshalb eine nachhaltige
stärkung von angeboten der kinder und
jugendhilfe stadt hier und da
projektförderung wie sie wieder im
vertrag festgeschrieben ist bei denen
niemand ohne aktion versteht wie man
diese verträge überhaupt ausfüllen muss
brauchen wir investitionen in
nachhaltige strukturen denn es bringt
nichts
wenn sich sozialarbeiter innen ein
prestige-projekt nach dem nächsten
ausdenken müssen damit politiker in
damit in der presse glänzen denn
sozialarbeit ist kein wettbewerb sie ist
eine zentrale öffentliche aufgabe und
dass das müssen wir endlich
doch zwischen diesen schritt weiter
gehen denn wie viele kinder kommen
hungrig in die schule wie viele kinder
können nicht mit zum schulausflug wie
viele kinder schaffen ist vielleicht
sich gerade noch den beitrag für den
fußballverein zu leisten aber nicht mehr
die schule dafür ja es geht um
kinderarmut jedes fünfte kind lebt in
armut und sie sagen die
kindergrundsicherung soll kommen aber
bleiben völlig unkonkret dabei um
welchen betrag es sich denn handelt und
deswegen empfehle ich in unserem antrag
aus dem märz 2020 wir werden konkret
altersabhängig bis zu 36 euro
grundbetrag plus erstattung von kosten
für wohnung und sonderbedarf für so
einfach kann es sein so gut so recht
doch noch unwichtiger als kinderarmut
scheint für sie altersarmut zu sein wenn
das wort wird im gesamten
koalitionsvertrag nicht einmal erwähnt
dabei lebt ein fünftel aller seniorinnen
in armut
interessant auch wie ein interessantes
thema alleinerziehende für sie zu sein
scheint die werden das möchte ich ihr
sagen fünf mal erwähnt aber ohne
erkennbare strategie um deren situation
wirklich zu verbessern und auch hier in
richtig ungern 43 prozent aller
alleinerziehenden leben in armut die
pandemie hat sie ganz besonders belastet
und wenn minister heil jetzt mit großem
tamtam als erste maßnahme 40 prozent
zuschuss für haushaltshilfen ankündigt
dann das ist doch absurd denn wer kann
sich denn so eine haushaltshilfe leisten
und welche art von jobs wird denn damit
finanziert sind rhetorische fragen aber
da habe ich im ernst damit wollen sie
jetzt der gleichstellung einläuten aber
frau ministerin spiegelt sie sagen sie
seien für mindesten und das freut mich
außerordentlich ich verbinde damit die
hoffnung dass die angekündigten vorhaben
der ampel um die situation von frauen zu
verbessern zügig auf den weg gebracht
werden und ich hoffe sie schaffen es auf
sich gegen die handschrift der fdp
durchzusetzen dass die gesamte
konvention beispielsweise endlich
umgesetzt werden soll ist dabei weniger
ein großer wurf der neuen als er ein
versagen der alten regierung wirksam
umgesetzt heißt übrigens dass wir unter
anderem 14.000 plätze mehr in
frauenhäusern brauchen und dafür
entsprechende investitionen was damit
ihnen liebe kolleginnen von der fdp
möglich ist das ist die große frage was
wir gut finde ist dass sie zwei wochen
bezahlten urlaub für väter nach der
geburt einführen wollen das soll bitte
unabhängig vom geschlecht für das zweite
elternteil gelten und auch für
alleinerziehende und das übrigens ist
eine linke idee wir haben die letztes
jahr hier eingebracht damals hat die spd
leider noch dagegen bestimmt schön dass
er sich jetzt anders überlegt haben
liebe kolleginnen wir sehen mal wieder
links wirkt und bei ihren guten projekte
sind wir an ihrer seite und ansonsten
rücken wir die soziale frage als einzig
soziale opposition im haus natürlich in
den mittelpunkt vielen dank
heidi reich mit mit ihrer ersten rede
sie ist die frauenpolitische sprecherin
der linken
die grünen ist die familienpolitische
sprecherin mit
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen zusammen loslegen so wie es
an spiegel gerade angekündigt hat ja
darauf freuen wir uns endlich den
aufbruch gestalten ich kann ihnen sagen
so viele haben sich nach den
koalitionsverhandlungen bei uns bei mir
gemeldet und gesagt jetzt kann ich
richtig aufatmen teure vielen vorhaben
für eine fortschrittliche
gesellschaftspolitik geben mir echt
hoffnung und ich sage ihnen das hat mich
echt berührt in diesem geist werden wir
also loslegen damit auch hoffnungen
realitäten werden in enger
zusammenarbeit mit der ministerin und
dem gesellschafts ministerium für
familien frauen jugend seniorinnen queer
und für eine moderne gesellschaft der
vielen daran arbeiten wir mit aller
kraft unser ziel ist bestehende
lebensrealitäten anzuerkennen und jedem
menschen zu ermöglichen sicher frei und
in würde leben zu können wir wollen dass
ein selbstbestimmtes leben für frauen
für menschen mit internationaler
familiengeschichte für tiere menschen
für junge und alte gestärkt und
abgesichert wird das unsägliche
diskriminierungen die es noch immer gibt
endlich abgeschafft werden
ich kann in drei minuten nur ein paar
punkte nennen aber endlich alle familien
konstellationen in denen menschen in
liebe und verantwortung miteinander
leben abzusichern das heißt fortschritt
genau diesen fortschritt hat die union
16 jahre verhindert und die europäer hat
gerade ich finde sehr giftig unter
beweis gestellt dass politik an den
realitäten von familien vorbei gemacht
worden ist da helfen auch flugzeug
nichts was ist nicht
die kolleginnen und kollegen ist
entstauben und gesetzen wären wir nicht
dem bundesverfassungsgericht
überlassen wir passen das abstimmungs
recht an und sichern kindern mit zwei
müttern von anfang an die sicherheit die
soziale elternschaft stärken wir mit
einem kleinen sorgerecht ein großer
schritt in punkto gerechtigkeit und
gegen kinderarmut wird die einführung
der kindergrundsicherung und für
gerechte beteiligung sorgt das absenken
des wahlalters auf 16 jahre das sind
klare ziele unserer ampelkoalition
und
mir liegt am herzen dass die gewalt
nicht verbessern frauenhäusern endlich
mit aus dem bund finanzieren und die
vorbehaltlose umsetzung der islam
konsens konvention voranbringen an
selbstbestimmung setzt das seinem namen
gerecht wird werden wir auf den weg
bringen grund werden § 209 10 h schnell
und endgültig streichen und eine lösung
für paragraf 218 außerhalb des
strafgesetzbuches beraten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
so viele menschen haben auf ein bundes
partizipations gesetz gewartet das wird
ebenso kommen wie unser verstärkter
kampf gegen rechtsextremismus aber und
das mit allen verbänden und angeles ohne
die jahrzehntelangen kämpfen der
zivilgesellschaft werden wir nie so weit
gekommen darum danke an alle die hier
gekämpft haben ich komme zum schluss
wir wagen das positive jedem menschen zu
gestehen geschützt abgesichert und
selbstbestimmt zu leben den realitäten
von menschen gerecht werden denn so
leben wir in unserem land modern und
normal vielfältig und genauso sollten
gesetze aussehen in diesem sinne auf
geht's
gute chance von den bündnisgrünen
natürlich zufrieden mit dem
koalitionsvertrag mit ihrer ministerin
was sollte es auch anders sein und sie
via brief die stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende der cdu csu ist in der
bundestagsfraktion sprecherin für
familie senioren frauen und jugend wird
das sicherlich anders sehen und sie
bekommt jetzt das wort
[Musik]
auch mal von mir herzlichen glückwunsch
zu ihrem amt und viel erfolg zum wohle
aller familien in deutschland denn ihr
koalitionsvertrag verspricht viel nicht
nur gesellschaftspolitisch ist
verspricht vor allen dingen auch viel
geld und ich möchte nur mal ein paar
überschriften nennen sofort zuschlag
kindergrundsicherung elterngeld
haushaltsnahe dienstleistungen
anschlussprogramm für unser corona
aufhol programm und fortführung der
mittel für unser gute kita gesetz viele
gut klingen die überschriften das ist
richtig aber es ist eben alles nicht nur
eine frage der haltung sondern auch eine
frage der finanzierung und deswegen gehe
ich davon aus dass sie mehr als nur
einen guten draht zu ihrem
finanzminister haben der trotz
schuldenbremse ihren haushalt erheblich
wird aufstocken müssen der sie sind ihre
versprechen an die familien ihr kehrt
versprechen die einführung einer
kindergrundsicherung
diese debatte ist nicht neu nein richtig
wir haben diese debatte schon oft
geführt und deswegen frage ich mich
warum
warum haben sie noch keine antworten
noch keine ideen für einen weg und haben
den aktuell eher nach dem motto wenn ich
nicht mehr weiter weiß gründe ich einen
arbeitskreis das ist mir an dieser
stelle definitiv zu wenig und weil es
eben länger dauert gibt es nun sofort
zuschlag sofort zuschlagen wer bekommt
ihn denn wie viel man monatlich unter
jährlich antworten auf diese fragen kann
bis jetzt noch niemand geben aus dieser
bundesregierung und dann gibt es später
die kindergrundsicherung
garantiebetrag für jedes kind gibt es
schon den nennen das kindergeld und ein
eltern einkommen unabhängig gestaffelten
zusatzbetrag gibt es übrigens heute auch
schon wir nennen das kinderzuschlag und
bildungs und teilhabepaket und die
leistungen sollen zusammengefasst und in
einem neuen neuen digitalen kinder
chancen portal einfach automatisiert
berechnet und ausgezahlt werden zitiere
ich ich kann sie beruhigen wie die
buckower die arbeit können sie sich
sparen die haben wir nämlich in der
letzten legislatur bereits gemacht mit
dem digitalen familienleistungsgesetz
die rechtlichen grundlagen sind
geschaffen sie müssen es nur noch
umsetzen
und jedes kind in deutschland das unter
sind das sozial benachteiligt es ist
eines zu viel und wenn sie gute ideen
haben haben sie uns an ihrer seite aber
ihr wunsch dass die leistungen aus der
kindergrundsicherung nun direkt beim
kind ankommen
ganz ehrlich das doch eine leere phrase
das geld wird immer in den familien
ankommen und nicht direkt beim kind fakt
ist geld alleine hilft nicht damit
bekommt noch kein kind was heute ohne
frühstück in die schule kommt danach mit
frühstück durch oder einem gesunden
essen durch den tag hier gilt es auch
zukünftig kinder und eltern familien zu
unterstützen und zwar zielgerichtet und
bedarfsorientiert mit guten und
verlässlichen
bildungseinrichtungen und
betreuungsangeboten flächendeckenden
anderer stellen für familien der mit
leistungen auch abgerufen werden und vor
allen dingen die eltern in
erwerbstätigkeit zu bringen das war und
das ist unser anspruch als union
und sie kündigen eine umfassende reform
des sorge und umgangsrecht es an studien
sollen diese vorhaben begleiten aber
bitte machen sie nicht den zweiten
schritt vor dem ersten diese studien
müssen grundlage von rechtlichen
entscheidungen sein und in diesem
zusammenhang frage ich sie nach der
teuren forschungsstudie kindeswohl und
trennung was ist daraus geworden was im
bmf j unter spd-führung in auftrag
gegeben wurde für 1,2 millionen der
datenschutzbeauftragte hat die studie
gestoppt zumindest unsere informationen
aber genau diese infos brauchen wir wenn
wir an sorge und umgangsrecht gehen denn
für uns als union steht immer das
kindeswohl an erster stelle
und dann sprechen sie auch heute frau
ministerin über die zweiwöchige
freistellung des partners nach einer
geburt bei vollem gehalt so weit so gut
sie verraten nur nicht wer das bezahlen
soll vielleicht der arbeitgeber aber
dieser freistellung entspricht entgegen
ihres heutigen artikels keine pflicht
aus der eu vereinbarkeit richtlinie das
sollten sie wird nicht besser wissen
frau ministerin mit unserem elterngeld
sind wir hier in deutschland nämlich
schon heute mehr als gut aufgestellt
eine weitere pflicht erwächst aus dem eu
recht nicht es braucht einfach mehr als
eine zweiwöchige freistellung und einem
weiteren monat elterngeld liebe chor
bessere wahlfreiheit mehr
zeitsouveränität und das über das
gesamte berufsleben diese vision neue
und alte instrumente zusammen denn diese
haben wir und das erwarten wir auch von
ihm insofern wünschen wir ihnen viel
erfolg bei der umsetzung
den nächsten jahren dankeschön und
[Applaus]
zu seiner ersten rede erteile ich das
wort daniel wall die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen mit
bundesfamilienministerin frau spiegel
verbindet mich nicht nur die überzeugung
der ampel als fortschritts koalition als
reiner verrinnen und rheinland pfälzer
haben wir in unserem heimatbundesland in
den letzten fünf jahren auch sehen
können dass die ampel koalition sehr
gute arbeit geleistet hat die menschen
überzeugt und wie sehr sie überzeugt hat
das haben wir beide und auch das ganze
land im vergangenen märz bei der
landtagswahl sehen können gerade im
bereich der demokratie und engagement
politik wurden wichtige vorhaben nicht
nur angekündigten ein sie wurden auch
umgesetzt das ist auch unser anspruch
für den bund und ich bin mir sicher
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren wir
werden diesem anspruch auch gerecht
werden in der ampelkoalition
eines der projekte die die ampel
koalition in rheinland pfalz umgesetzt
hat ist die online-welt plattform empire
die im september 2020 für
menschenfeindliche rassistische und
antisemitische vorfälle eingerichtet
wurde und so der erste jahresbericht hat
uns gezeigt es war richtig diese
plattform einzurichten und zu schaffen
um vorfälle die leider oft im
verborgenen bleiben sichtbarer zu machen
aber die hässliche fratze des fasses wie
sie nannten frau spiegel sie zeigt sich
nicht nur in der anonymität des
internets die steigende zahl von
tätlichen angriffen auf engagierte und
ehrenamtliche müssen für uns grund zur
sorge sein mehr als 70 prozent der
partnerschaften für demokratie
unterstützt durch das programm
demokratie leben sind regelmäßig von
anfeindungen betroffen das dürfen wir
nicht tolerieren liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen
gefährdete personen brauchen und
verdienen unseren schutz und müssen sich
nicht nur aber allen voran in ihren
eigenen vier wänden sicher fühlen können
deshalb stärken wir die möglichkeit von
auskunftssperren und melderegister denn
eins ist klar wer für demokratische
werte wie vielfalt toleranz respekt und
freiheit eintritt der muss unter wird
von uns wo immer es geht auch
unterstützt werden
wir sollten zivilgesellschaftliches
engagement aber nicht nur vor angriffen
schützen nein wir sollten es auch
proaktiv fördern wir als spd
bundestagsfraktion machen das schon
lange denn wir waren ist die sonst in
der vergangenen legislaturperiode im
parlament aber auch in der regierung
vehement dafür eingesetzt haben die
programme für zivilgesellschaftliches
engagement langfristig auf solide
finanzielle füße zu stellen um es ganz
konkret zu machen allein das programm
demokratie leben fördert mehr als 320
lokale partnerschaften für demokratie 40
zivilgesellschaftliche organisationen
und 150 modellprojekte in ganz
deutschland aber all die wichtige arbeit
die dort geleistet wird hat sie wie bei
unionsfraktionen leider bisher nicht
überzeugen können sie sehen hinter jeder
organisation gegen rechts gespenster
linksextremer gewalt sie rücken dieses
bürgerschaftliche engagement in eine
antidemokratische schmuddelecke sie
stellen diese für unsere demokratie so
wertvoll streiterin und streiter unter
generalverdacht das war der grund warum
sie einen rückzieher gemacht haben beim
gesetzentwurf zum demokratie
fördergesetz in der letzten legislatur
selbst horst seehofer ihr innenminister
war zitat maßlos enttäuscht von ihrem
destruktiven handeln
dass wir als ampel koalition spätestens
im kommenden jahr nun endlich ein
solches gesetz vorlegen und
verabschieden wollen ist auch ein klares
zeichen an die vielen vereine und
initiativen im bereich der beratungs und
präventionsarbeit wir schätzen eure
arbeit wir wollen euch unterstützen ihr
könnt euch auf uns verlassen wir lassen
euch nicht im stich
wenn wir uns die ziele der kommenden
jahre anschauen dann gilt es einmal mehr
festzuhalten unsere demokratien feinde
und unsere demokratie wird bedroht und
wir man sehr geehrten damen und herren
haben die aufgabe sie zu verteidigen
alle demokratinnen und demokraten in
diesem wohnhaus müssen sich klar
positionieren ob sie nun in der
regierung sind und der opposition der
opposition den kampf gegen rechts und
für die demokratie müssen wir zusammen
führen daran werden wir uns als
parlament messen lassen müssen und sie
liebe links und liebe unionsfraktion
sind herzlich eingeladen diesen weg
gemeinsam mit uns zu gehen herzlichen da
hannibal die von der spd seine hörst du
leben hier im hohen hause
kommt er auf räumlicher blaues von
mehreren fraktionen vor allen dingen
natürlich aus einen eigenen reihen
christoph de vries wird der nächste
redner sein von der cdu/csu es schon
eine legislatur hier im haus er ist der
vorsitzende der gruppe der vertriebenen
aussiedler und deutschen minderheiten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir war
familienpolitik in dieser wahlperiode
reden dann müssen wir auch über den
schutz unserer kinder sprechen und zwar
ganz besonders auch über den schutz
unserer kinder vor sexualisierter gewalt
denn kindesmissbrauch zerstört kinder
sehen besprechen von tausenden fällen
jahr für jahr in deutschland und zwar
mit steigender tendenz werden im jahr
2020 einen anstieg beim kindesmissbrauch
um 7 prozent fast 14.000 500 fälle der
handel mit kinderpornografie hat
zugenommen immens um 53 prozent auf 18
1700 fälle meine damen und herren das
sind erschütternde zahlen und das sind
keine zahlen die es uns als parlament
erlauben in irgendeiner form hier die
hände in den schoß zu legen und tatenlos
zuzuschauen und
es ist hochaktuell
das gestern und sie werden es
mitbekommen haben sind die ergebnisse
der soko berg in nordrhein-westfalen
publik geworden in zwei jahren sind dort
65 kinder befreit worden
439 tatverdächtige internet infiziert
worden das jüngste opfer ein drei monate
altes baby was vergewaltigt wurde das
macht ein als vater von drei kindern
sprachlos und frau ministerin ich hätte
mir schon an dieser stelle einen tag
nach dieser bekanntmachung gewünscht
dass sie dazu ein paar worte der
anteilnahme sagen und dass sie dem
parlament auch sagen was sie politisch
gegen kindesmissbrauch in den nächsten
vier jahren unternehmen wollen
die unionsfraktion hat sich die
konsequente bekämpfung des
kindesmissbrauchs seit langem auf die
fahnen geschrieben das ist ja kein
geheimnis
während den sexuellen kindesmissbrauch
als verbrechen eingestuft werden den
strafräumen erhöht wir haben den besitz
und die verbreitung von
kinderpornografie hat verbrechen auch
strafrechtlich hochgestuft wir haben das
zeigt wo unter strafe gestellt wir haben
vor allen dingen aber auch die
möglichkeiten der sicherheitsbehörden im
internet gestärkt indem ermittler nun
recht aussehende computergenerierte
bilder hoch laufen können damit man dort
zugang kriegt zu diesen
kinderpornografischen fuhren um dort
vermitteln zu können das alles ist
wirklich beachtlich aber das ist noch
lange nicht genug und unser anspruch als
unionsfraktion ist und bleibt dass wir
hier speerspitze im parlament leimen
wollen im kampf gegen den
kindesmissbrauch
und das finden wir dazu im
koalitionsvertrag
eine dürftige seite mit einem drittel
absatz außer allgemeinplätzen und rasen
findet sich beim schutz vor
kindesmissbrauch nichts substanzielles
keine konkreten maßnahmen liebe kollegen
kollegen der ampel das reicht nicht denn
die zahlen machen uns ja eindringlich
zum handeln ich habe das eben
fortgeführt zu mehr aufklärung zu mehr
ermittlungen und auch zu mehr
rechtlichen befugnissen der polizei und
ich will nur zwei forderungen nennen die
werden vielen stellen deutlich gemacht
haben wir wollen das internet dienste
verpflichtet werden bei kenntnis von
sexuell missbraucht das bestandsdaten an
die mitten ermittler weitergegeben
werden müssen und wir wollen das sage
ich auch mit blick auf die rede des
justizministers gestern die ich an der
steller schottern fand dass es auf
europäischer ebene eine
grundrechtskonforme regelung zur
verpflichtenden staat speicherung von ip
daten gibt die ermittler die die
ermittlung der täter ermöglicht meine
damen und herren von der ampel ihr
kategorisches nein zur
vorratsdatenspeicherung
beraubt ihr mittlerer schärfsten waffe
jährlich können tausende fälle von
kinderpornografie nicht aufgeklärt
werden weil diese verbindungsdaten
fehlen und was sie hier aus
datenschutzgründen rechtlichen gründen
ablehnen hartnäckig ist in der realität
in tausenden fällen freifahrtschein für
kinderschänder und für skrupellose
geschäftemacher in unserem land dieses
verhalten leistet den missbrauch von
kindern forschung und dem handel mit
diesen abscheulichen zeug was dort
verbreitet wird ich muss an dieser
stelle einmal ganz deutlich sagen
und unser grundsatz gilt hier weiter
datenschutz darf nicht zum täterschutz
werden seien sich dessen immer bewusst
bei ihren entscheidungen die sie in den
nächsten jahren familienpolitisch aber
auch rechtspolitisch treffen werden wir
werden ihnen das nicht durchgehen lassen
und wir werden an dieser stelle immer
wieder den finger in die wunde legen
vielen dank
bis hier mit einem ganz eigenen beitrag
zu dem thema familien senioren frauen
und jugend ein wichtiges thema durchaus
was er dort angesprochen hat der nächste
redner in der debatte ist martin gassner
herz und die einer ersten rede erteile
ich das wort martin gassner herz fdp
fraktion
das beste sagt er mit seiner ersten rede
vor dem haus
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren welch ein für mich
beeindruckendes ereignis hier an dieser
stelle meine erste rede halten zu dürfen
neu gewählter abgeordneter zu sein
bedeutet logischerweise ja auch dass man
noch unlängst einem anderen beruf
nachgegangen ist so war ich bis vor
kurzem im jobcenter in offenburg
beschäftigt und damit in der ersten
reihe wo unser sozialsystem auf menschen
treffen denen sie eine stütze sein
sollen gute sozialsysteme sind eine
aufstiegs leiter mit der sich stolze
menschen aus einer schwierigen situation
emanzipieren
mit diesen gedanken selbstbestimmten
vorankommens bin ich den weg gegangen
der mich bis hierher in den deutschen
bundestag getragen hat diese aufstiegs
leider fehlen gerade an ihrem beginn
noch entscheidende sprossen die
sozialpolitik der freien demokraten wird
gemeinsam mit den sozialdemokratischen
und grünen partnern neue und dichtere
sprossen schaffen
besonders niedrige und enge sprossen
brauchen dabei diejenigen mit den
kürzesten beiden und das sind die kinder
wir wollen kinder aus hartz iv heraus
und ermöglichen für sie eine teilhabe
die nicht mit der bewältigung von
unzähligen formularen verbunden ist mit
der kindergrundsicherung machen wir
einen großen schritt zu einer echten
chancengerechtigkeit zu
oft haben bürokratischen hürden bisher
verhindert dass hilfe dort angelangt wo
sie gebraucht wird das wird sich nun
ändern die kindergrundsicherung wird
unbürokratisch und gut zugänglich bisher
verschiedene leistungen zusammenführen
sie wird digitaler sein und mehr kindern
einfachere bessere chancen zur teilhabe
an gemeinschaft gesellschaft bildung und
mobilität eröffnen die familienpolitik
der fortschritts regierung wird außerdem
jene im blick haben deren wünsche wie
sie familie sein möchten noch nicht
erfüllt sind wir werden mit der
verantwortungsgemeinschaft oder
änderungen im adoptionsrecht dazu neu
möglich eröffnung
ein besonderes herz das thema ist mir
dass mehr paare die bisher unerfüllte
kinderwünsche finanziell hat haben
finanziell entlasten werden wenn sie
medizinische unterstützung in anspruch
nehmen müssen wir werden außerdem mehr
menschen zugang zu dieser förderung
verschaffen aus eigener erfahrung weiß
sich ein solcher weg ist so häufig mit
rückschlägen verbunden und für
betroffene paare sowohl seelisch als
auch körperlich extrem belastend wie
furchtbar muss es sein wenn man
zusätzlich dazu noch sorgen um die
finanzierbarkeit der behandlung haben
muss auch die beste sozialpolitik kann
nicht jede schwierigkeit des lebens
abwenden aber sollte dort leid mindern
wo es möglich ist
familie in all ihren vielfältigen formen
sind die uhr zellen der gesellschaft aus
ihnen heraus bilden wir gemeinschaften
in ihr sind wir stolze bürgerinnen und
bürger und bilden damit das fundament
der demokratie
gerade in diesen für die gesellschaft
belastenden zeiten hat die fortschritts
koalition im blick den zusammenhalt zu
stärken
bürgerschaftliches engagement ist das
rückgrat einer starken gesellschaft und
einer integrativen demokratie wir
begeistern mehr besonders junge menschen
für das ehrenamt wir fördern das
vereinsleben wir stärken damit jene die
aus der mitte der gesellschaft unseren
zusammenleben tragen damit rücken wir
respekt aus gegenüber den großen
leistungen die menschen im ehrenamt und
damit in ihrer freizeit vollbringen und
die dann und die der staat wie leisten
können
wir machen unsere gesellschaft mit einer
starken bürgerschaft aber auch
widerstandsfähig gegen jene die
versuchen die gesellschaft zu
untergraben und spalt pilze zubereiten
dazu werden wir an demokratie
fördergesetz arbeiten die familien und
gesellschaftspolitik der koalition wird
wunderbares erreichen und ich habe große
lust darauf gemeinsam mit ihnen mit
dieser umsetzung endlich loszulegen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
und da sehen wir schon die nächste reden
ein bild auf der seite top frau in
familien
für die
csu jetzt kein pardon anke hennig ist
zunächst
von der spd hieß es im ausschuss für
familie senioren frauen und jugend der
werte frau präsidentin sehr geehrte frau
ministerin spiegel sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen
jedes kind hat rechte auf der ganzen
welt egal in welchem land sie leben und
aus welchem sozialen umfeld sie stammen
jedes einzelne kind
diese kinderrechte müssen in unserem
wichtigsten gesetz dass wir in
deutschland haben verankert werden im
grundgesetz
immer rechte stärken bedeutet dabei
nicht dass eltern in ihren geschwächt
werden ganz im gegenteil wenn erwachsene
wissen wo die rechte ihrer kinder liegen
ist ein fundament geschaffen dass beide
seiten stärken wird
in der un kinderrechtskonvention steht
geschrieben dass kinder in der
gesellschaft beteiligt werden müssen sie
müssen geschützt und gefördert werden
auf all das hat sich die koalition
geeinigt
ich bin sehr froh dieses längst
überfällige thema jetzt zeitnah angehen
zu können und ich bin mir sicher dass es
durch einen grundgesetz eintrag gelingen
wird die welt für die kleinsten in
unserer gesellschaft
komfortabler sicherer und unbeschwerter
zu machen
aufgrund des noch immer bestehenden
ungleichgewichts in der vielfältigkeit
vor allem in der familie ist es zur
befriedung wichtig auch ihre themen als
grundrechte zu definieren die diese
menschen zu gleichberechtigten mit
menschen machen auf augenhöhe ein
selbstbestimmtes leben mit akzeptanz ist
erst möglich wenn man ein mensch mit
gleichen rechten in unserer streitkultur
der aufklärung ist
deshalb werden wir gleichstellung
verwirklichen das bedeutet und es ist
mir an dieser stelle nach der
unsäglichen rede des herrn reichert eine
genugtuung sagen zu können
vielfältige familienmodelle werden
rechtlich abgesichert von uns
regenbogenfamilien werden zusätzlich
darin unterstützt füreinander sorge zu
tragen und verantwortung zu übernehmen
wenn sich mehrere menschen mit oder
anstelle der biologischen eltern um ihre
kinder kümmern und
auch ein sehr veraltetes abstimmungs
recht werden wir überarbeiten und mit
modernen auf den weg bringen es müssen
gleiche rechte von
gleichgeschlechtlichen
partnerinnen und partnern in der ehe
gelten insbesondere bei adoptionen und
auch pflegschaften
das transsexuellengesetz
ist unrecht und muss abgeschafft werden
aus demselben grund werden wir ein
selbstbestimmungsrechts verabschieden
das die entwürdigenden psychischen
begutachtung und die diskriminierung von
trans personen auch vor dem gesetz
endgültig beendet und sie vor diesem
gleichgestellt sind
das diskriminierungsverbot wegen der
geschlechtlichen und sexuellen identität
wird in artikel 3 absatz 3 grundgesetz
aufgenommen die ausnahmeregelungen beim
diskriminierungsschutz für religions-
und weltanschauungsgemeinschaften
sollen enger gefasst sein und damit den
individuellen rechten deutlich mehr
geltung verschaffen
nur weil jemand anbieter glaubt darf er
sich nicht ausgenommen fühlen wir wollen
gleiche rechte nicht aber unklare
grundsätzlich im zusammenleben mit aller
konsequenz
außerdem brauchen wir mehr engagement
und sichtbarkeit in anerkennung und
gleichstellung von lesben schwule
bisexuelle
transgender und ihren menschen die kurze
bezeichnung ist alles ptq das bedeutet
auf eine pädagogik der vielfalt und
somit die berücksichtigung der lsb in
unterrichtseinheiten
und in schulbüchern
die rechtliche absicherung
von lsb kyu familien und trans und
interpersonelle
überfällig
zusätzlich brauchen wir einen nationalen
aktionsplan gegen homo bi trans und
internist und gewalt gegen lsb die kuh
und wir müssen uns auch auf europäischer
ebene für die ächtung solcher
diskriminierung intensiv einsetzen
zu guter letzt werden wir die richtlinie
der bundesärztekammer zur blutspende
anpassen und jeder soll blut spenden
dürfen völlig unabhängig der sexuellen
orientierung und geschlechtsidentität
unser familienbegriff oder unser
verständnis von familie ist sehr weit
gefasst er zeichnet sich durch
vielfältigkeit aus daher bin ich umso
glücklicher dass wir in unserer
regierungskoalition in den nächsten vier
jahren eine breite und fortschrittliche
politik machen können vielen dank
banken von der spd auch sie hat heute
hier ihre erste rede gehalten im
deutschen parlament und die nächste
rednerin müsste jetzt aber keinerlei hat
sein und da steht sie jetzt wirklich die
opfer im familienausschuss für die
cdu/csu bis 14
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe frau ministerin spiegel wir alle
bekommen ganz ganz viele mails von
imkern von sogenannten spaziergängern
und ich habe mich auf befragten letzter
zeit wie es wäre wenn wir genauso viele
mails bekommen würden von jugendlichen
und kindern und ich bin wirklich leid so
sage ich ganz offen dass wir den lauten
so viel aufmerksamkeit schenken und auch
in ihrer rede kam mir das thema corona
und kinder leider etwas kurz und
vielleicht liegt es auch daran dass ein
stringentes konzept mit blick auf die
bekämpfung der korona pandemie dass er
dazu führen würde dass die situation für
kinder und jugendliche sicherer werden
würde in unserem land leider fehlt und
leider geht ob omas politik geprägt ist
von einem großen zaudern und abfahrten
der ampel kult koalitionäre
was wir brauchen liebe spd und liebe
ambri koalitionäre ist viel mehr respekt
sie eines ihrer lieblingswörter
gegenüber diejenigen die wie unsere
schulkinder sechs stunden am tag
diszipliniert ihre masken tragen und
viel mehr respekt den familien gegenüber
in unserem land die großartiges
geleistet haben
nach wie vor stärkste ausdruck dieser
zögerlichkeit und ich bin ehrlich gesagt
bis heute nicht ganz darüber hinweg dass
die die pandemische lage einfach
ausgesetzt haben ist genau diese
aussetzung die dann zum glück
nachgesteuert wurde nachgebessert wurde
von ihrer seite zum glück können heute
die kinder wieder in die schule gehen
aber ich sage auch ganz deutlich
nachbessern und glück sind keine
regierungshandeln und wir erwarten von
ihnen einfach langfristige konzepte und
die nötige weitsicht
und wenn man sich jetzt so wissen um
schaut wie sie darauf reagieren dann
kann man überhaupt nicht feststellen
dass es so irgendwas geben würde wie
überhaupt einigkeit mit blick auf die
pandemie bekämpfung und es ist wirklich
bemerkenswert wie der herr kubicki von
der fdp und frau casselman von den
grünen wie weit ich hier nach wie vor
auseinander liegen und dabei ist eins
ganz ganz klar es geht so sagt auch die
vorsitzende des ethikrats es geht um die
solidarität mit kindern und mit
jugendlichen und dabei muss sowohl die
schule als auch das soziale leben der
kinder für uns alle die höchste
priorität haben
stellen wir uns doch mal weniger die
frage wie es stehen spaziergängern geht
sondern wie es am drittklässler in
unserem land geht der vor zwei jahren
ganz normal eingeschult wurde dann kam
der locker und dann kam homeschooling
und distanz unterricht und zu hause hat
sich der stress in den familien erhöht
weil es einfach schwierig ist ein kind
zu unterrichten und gleichzeitig selbst
zu arbeiten fast drei millionen
grundschülerinnen grundschule ging es so
in unserem land wir denken an die
studierende die nicht richtig studieren
konnten an die schülerinnen und schüler
die ein bisschen größer sind und deshalb
sehr geehrte
ampelkoalition ehre meine große bitte an
sie und liebe frau ministerin ist es da
noch mal ganz genau hinzuschauen es gibt
dringenden handlungsbedarf die haben sie
schon gehört die suizidversuche bei
kindern sind um fast 300 prozent
gestiegen
die klinisch relevanten depressiven
symptome bei kindern im alter von 16 bis
sind von vorher zehn prozent auf jetzt
25 prozent gestiegen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
was wir brauchen im jahr 2022 und diese
learnings dürften ja langsam bei allen
angekommen sein ist genau das was uns
jugendpsychologen und
bildungswissenschaftler sei was kinder
am meisten brauchen jetzt ist sicherheit
sie brauchen die sicherheit dass sie
weiterhin fußball spielen können in
ihren vereinen dass die schulen offen
bleiben dass sie sich mit freundinnen
und freunden treffen können und
geburtstage feiern können und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der ampel
sorgen sie bitte hier für einen klaren
kurs sorgen sie für die sicherheit
unserer kinder vielen dank
soweit also katia leikert der nächste
redner hier in der debatte ist johannes
huber er ist seit dem ersten januar
fraktionslos ist auch aus der afd
ausgetreten sowohl eben aus der kartei
wie auch aus der fraktion und redet
jetzt hier als eine
das positive vorweg es ist absolut
notwendig das heim und pflegekinder die
eigenen einkünfte komplett behalten das
befreit kinder aus der armut und es sind
positiver leistungsanreiz den in der
letzten legislatur zuerst die
fdp-fraktion und später auch die fdp
gefordert haben die kindergrundsicherung
ist vor allem bei hilfsbedürftigen
eltern aber kein leistungsanreiz dass
sich die erwerbsarbeit im sinne der
hilfe zur selbsthilfe lohnt stattdessen
handelt es sich hier um einen
etikettenschwindel weil das geld in den
meisten fällen nicht bei den
minderjährigen kindern selbst ankommt in
wahrheit versucht die ampel hier in
erster schritt zum bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen zu unternehmen wenn sie
das schon tun dann zahlen sie wenigstens
ehrlich zu den bürgern da draußen besser
wäre es wenn sie bereits jetzt das
kindliche existenzminimum mit
ausreichenden kinderfreibeträgen
gewährleisten aber hier hat sich die fdp
nicht gegen die sozialistische rest
ampel durchsetzen können für kinder und
jugendliche haben übrigens alle
grundrechte solange gegolten bis sie vom
unverhältnismäßig heiligen
infektionsschutz ausgehebelt wurden
gesonderte kinderrechte im grundgesetz
zu verankern und olaf scholz die
lufthoheit über die kinderbetten zu
erlauben ist also überhaupt nicht
notwendig sondern eine alte
sozialistische traumvorstellung die
eltern infolge dieser kulturellen
evolution komplett zugunsten der
regierung zu entmündigen liebe cdu csu
die eltern und kinder in der
bundesrepublik erwarten von ihnen dass
sie das zusammen mit der afg verhindern
die ampel regierung will nämlich die
familiären bindungen entwerten bzw
komplett auflösen dass alleinerziehende
mit einer steuergutschrift besser
gestellt werden ist ein fataler anreiz
beziehungen zu trennen und das
kindeswohl zu gefährden kinder sollen
sogar vor der empfängnis mit einem
schritt hin zur legalisierung der
leihmutterschaft verschachert werden
aber noch schlimmer mit der
verantwortungsgemeinschaft jenseits von
liebesbeziehungen
begehen sie an den anschlag auf das
grundgesetz und den artikel 6 durch den
ehe und familie unter dem besonderen
schutz der staatlichen ordnung stehen
kommen sie und ich komme zum schluss mit
einem appell an die regierung zurück auf
dem boden der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung und setzen
sie unsere familien und kinder nicht
ihren gesellschaftlichen experimenten
aus vielen dank
[Applaus]
denken sie bitte an ihre maske wenn sie
zum platz gehen vielen dank und ich
erteile das wort dem letzten redner in
der debatte für seine erste rede im
deutschen bundestag felix döring spd
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren mehr fortschritt wagen
das ist das motto das sich diese
koalition auf die fahnen schreibt und
deswegen möchte ich meine erste rede im
deutschen bundestag einem projekt dieser
ampelkoalition widmen zudem dieses motto
mehr fortschritt wagen passt wie die
faust aufs auge
es geht um ein gesetz das schon im
letzten jahrhundert so wirkte als sei es
von vorgestern es geht um einen alten
paragrafen der nicht nur verstaubt und
antiquiert wirkt sondern der in seinem
grundsatz falsch ist und auch reaktionär
meine damen und herren die rede ist von
paragrafen
219 album geht es geht darum stellen sie
sich vor sie müssen einen medizinischen
eingriff vornehmen lassen und ihre
zuständige ärztin ihr zuständige arzt
darf sie nicht darüber informieren dass
er oder sie diesen eingriff durchführen
kann und was das bedeutet dieser zustand
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist nicht
hinnehmbar und es wird deswegen gut dass
diese ampel sehr zügig und sehr rasch
und aus tiefer überzeugung heraus den
paragrafen 219 a streichen wird denn es
kann nicht sein dass frauen mit dieser
realität im jahre 2022 in deutschland
wenn sie einen schwangerschaftsabbruch
in erwägung ziehen müssen konfrontiert
sind dafür werden wir sorge tragen
und in meinem wahlkreis hat dieses thema
eine besondere brisanz ich komme aus
diesen dort lebt und praktiziert die
ärztin christina henne christina himmel
hat informiert hat aufgeklärt hat
beraten man könnte eigentlich auch sagen
sie hat eigentlich nur ihren job gemacht
und es beschämt mich zutiefst dass sie
aufgrund der geltenden rechtslage
mittlerweile eine verurteilte
straftäterin ist liebe frau handle ich
weiß dass sie zuhören ich sende ihnen
von dieser stelle und im namen aller
kolleginnen und kollegen dieses
parlament die sich ebenso wie ich und
ebenso wie diese koalition dem
gesellschaftlichen fortschritt
verpflichtet fühlen einen herzlichen
gruß der solidarität
aber wir belassen es nicht nur bei
solidarität wir werden erstens dafür
sorgen dass schwangerschaftsabbrüche
teil der ärztlichen ausbildung sein
werden wir werden zweitens die
versorgungssicherheit verbessern
verbessern und drittens dafür sorgen
dass gehsteig belästigungen von
sogenannten lebensschützern der gebotene
einheit gegeben wird und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in einer
umfrage aus dem jahr 2018 hat eine
repräsentative mehrheit von mehr als
zwei drittel der befragten gesagt ja
ärztinnen und ärzte sollten das recht
haben diese informationen auf ihrer
homepage zu veröffentlichen die
gesellschaftliche mehrheit für das
unterfangen den 219 abzuschaffen die ist
doch längst vorhanden meine damen und
herren die es längst vorhanden
gescheitert ist dieses projekt damals am
widerstand der union liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von der union den
eigentlich notwendigen
gesellschaftlichen fortschritt völlig
unnötigerweise auszubremsen das ist ihre
traurige kernkompetenz aber damit wird
jetzt schluss sein meine damen und
herren wir werden dafür sorgen dass aus
dieser gesellschaftlichen mehrheit die
abschaffung des 219 jetzt auch eine
parlamentarische mehrheit wird und wir
werden so mit dafür sorge tragen dass
sich der fortschritt seinen weg bahnt
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
und
wir sind am schluss dieser debatte
weitere wortmeldungen zu diesem
themenbereich liegen nicht vor